tonton album s'appelle addiction alors
justement ce que tu as une addiction pas
une édition quelques jours mais dix
mille les addictions cmd de mes défauts
principaux
c'est quoi j'aime un truc je le fais
comme un obsédé comme quelqu'un qui ne
peut pas s'arrêter de le faire je ne
m'arrête pas ça peut être les jeux vidéo
ça peut être le foot mais à chaque fois
ça me lasse à un moment parce que j'y
vais trois fonds est la seule chose qui
m'a jamais lassé c'est la musique
explique ge en fait je suis addict et je
m'arrête pas et j'adore ça et je veux
faire ça tous les jours tu vois par
exemple benjamin castaldi lui a dicté le
mariage
alors justement on va boire autour de la
table et beauty chez vous on va si tout
le monde autour de la table et aussi
prisonnier de ses addictions et vous
lever la main pour une conduite qui
serait capable d'arrêter de fumer et de
le faire tout de suite
voilà cliquez vois pas de ceux qui
fument l'hôtel
oui j'ai fumé des st moritz et machines
très long mars et poneys c'est la même
liberté si ça c'est pas de ça c'est pas
non mais c'est vrai bout quoi j'ai
arrêté le jour en mars y remercie pour
votre fille gentille l'inversé al mabry
ce qu'elle voulait que je joue je vais
demander ce qu'elle voyait comme cadeau
aux amis de sur le cadeau que je veux
c'est arrête de fumer même les plus
opaques et tziganes j'ai coupé en deux
jours
[Applaudissements]
sur la fère maxime gagnon va revenir
dans un instant vous inquiétez pas je
vous dirais que tu m'as balancé le
dossier qui serait capable de se laver
uniquement un jour sur deux pour
contribuer à nico vous avez tous les
jours mais bon je vous avais dit un jour
sur deux roues non non non je me lasse
que les gens mais quand j'ai pas le
temps parce que je me lève à 3h du matin
mais vous lever tous les jours à 3h du
matin non mais c'est pas grave ce sont
vous vous l'avez tout à fait comme les
chats moi je ficelé mais je transpire
pas mais remercie d'être là qui serait
capable de se passer de son téléphone
portable deux jours par semaine
vraiment sans problème vous avez pas
besoin portable ou boris higelin les
dans la loge m'entraide amené ici sinon
j'aurais pris les conversations à moi
mais non mais franchement vous en fichez
devrait ravir s'assure que tu pourrais
pas toi tu passé incapable ensuite les
deux heures à 12 heures moi je pourrais
pas deux heures deux heures je n'avais
pas une minute je peux pas franchement
vous pourriez mach aimerait j'aimerais
qu'on me l'imposé d'accord et ben ali
voir des gens vous allez voir des gens
non mais c'est vrai quoi attendait
madame madame qui irriguent nouvelle
masse oui mais là ils ont tous dit moi
je pourrais je pourrais y a personne qui
pourra vous rendez vous tiendrez peur ou
un voit dans les loges c'est quoi vb ont
fait le test quand tu me laisses on
passe par un week-end ensemble à
deauville sans téléphone sans rien alors
view et voilà et pas partir son
téléphone
je suis
- q accidents chez moi se remuer tout à
fait capable de se passer de sexe
pendant un mois bon maxime on sait que
ça va passer de meuf ou de mecs pendant
deux 2 pendant un mois mais je mendie de
la bête à vous voir moi quoi j'ai fait
deux fois par semaine mais je pourrais
m'en pas seulement de moi
where pauvres sont tu fais pas de voix
par semaine à mississauga s'ils sont
maria attendait les inerties mairie avec
ton mari
avec lui c'est une fois que son mari est
une fois rtl avec son amant non mais
c'est vrai et boyer pour les gens qu'on
est fatigué donc eh bien vous en passer
c'est à faire plaisir à l'un qui nous
regardent vous ils vous pourriez un mois
c'est beaucoup parce que à fatou me dit
moi je pourrais m'en passer dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
amenez on pourrait vous passiez de sexe
pendant un mois des fois je suis en
tournée pendant le saut et alors on
respecte les chanteurs nous rejoignent
sur la tournée semaines en mai et
pendant un an pendant un an non non non
c'est impossible albédo n'y est pas du
tout mais c'est une idée à la con fin je
sens que je vais me daniel 10 av du
touquet ce cas une idée pareille amassé
mois d'août
kadhafi n'est toi est ce que tu pourrais
t'en passer deux mois des projets pas
dit non et êtes vous maintenant possible
parce que je sais que votre fiancée et à
30 ans puisque vous c'est un 26 26 ans
de chez vous mais pourquoi vous dit
toujours personnelle et ses personnages
et c'est demain
mathé
[Applaudissements]
vous pourriez ah ah non non et puis un
mois nous flux à moi non plus data basil
katz impossible un impossible
moi je peux de quoi moi je peux 6-4 6-1
et vous en sortez moi je suis la reine
impossible impossible
quoi impossible et me cottet devient
possible on dirait que nous c'est ça mon
agressif quoi c'est à devenir un petit
bagarreur largement possible c'est
largement celle des mythos ben oui c'est
vrai voilà je pense qu est-ce qui est
graphiquement le fais moi on a envie
donc une fois qu'on tient à moi on peut
tenir après être demeuré regardez il ya
des mecs qu'ils ont connue 26 jours il
est tellement accroît son conjoint
qu'ils n'auraient pourrait pas s'en
passer pendant une semaine pour être
soir c'est bien vous êtes mariés depuis
combien de temps ça va faire 30 33 non
mariés marion ensemble on aimait on est
marié depuis chez pas plein d'années
c'était à 14 ans ne pouvez pas vous
passer d'elle une semaine a su du
mariage on souvent dire quoi mais ces
récits non vous n'êtes pas bien c'est
pas terrible non bah c'est beau ça part
en tournée
voici vous pouvez pas vous passer de
fatou bâ elle me manque quelques
quelques heures ça va mais deux ou trois
jours c'est impossible de savoir ce
qu'elle fait a réussi à le faire indique
de la tentation ou es ce que vous avez
dû sur l'île de la tentation germain je
vois pas tout qu'avez vous vu qu'il ya
des votants d'usagé merci oui vous vous
voyez non veux m'en passer pour une
semelle vote bout de ma fiancée
non non j'ai pas envie ville façon assez
ou tout rien dont où je peux vont passer
tout le temps où je peux pas me passer
du tout d'agressif alors dernière petite
question qui est bourrée et ça c'est
important de le savoir je voudrais avant
le savoir soit parce que c'est important
vous le disiez maintenant qui pourrait
se passer complètement de salaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ben quoi oui vous pourriez vous mais est
ce qu'on parle ici de tpm chose que oui
parce que du coup c'est plus un
défraiement qu'un salon
[Applaudissements]
on l'a déféré permettent depuis que j'ai
la chance de faire ce que je veux je
sais pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
le salaire parce que j'ai toujours
travaillé pour ma société
mais comme je le dis souvent je suis pas
le plus riche mais je suis le plus libre
et je sais pas le privilège que j'ai
salaires se connaît pas d'ailleurs j'ai
eu souvent des emmerdements et des
situations qui financièrement était pas
terrien vous mais je m'en fous non
seulement ils sont tous trop souvent
c'est vrai qu'elle aggrave mais
bienvenue au club
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
une fin en soi je d'annoncer paraître
merci